trois infos insolites sur les people 1le
peppers x est le plus puissant d'entre
eux il a été créé par être curie grâce
au croisement de plusieurs piment il
peut atteindre 3 millions cent
quatre-vingt mille unités sur l'échelle
de scoville l'échelle de mesure de la
force des piments c'est mille fois plus
que le piment d'espelette deux ailes et
piment extraterrestre ça existe en
novembre dernier thomas pesquet les
autres astronautes de liesse ont pu
goûter les premiers tacos spatiaux de
l'histoire grâce à des piments
entièrement cultivés dans l'espace c'est
la chaîne américaine megan mcarthur qui
avait lancé la culture de ces paiements
en juillet 2021 3 pour déguster la glace
la plus piquante du monde vous devez
vous rendre à glasgow en écosse dans la
halle gritche café le souffle du diable
c'est le nom de cette glace atteindrait
un million cinq cent soixante neuf 1300
unités sur l'échelle de scoville c'est
500 fois plus piquant que le tabasco
pour goûter il faut être âgé d'au moins
18 ans et signèrent une décharge